اهلا مصر وما ادراك ما الماسك لمن يكون
فائق ورايق ويقرر يحلل عده تويتر مو يحل
المزايا والاوضاع موظفين ولا سياسات
المنصه لا قرر يحلل علاقه تويتر بالنفس
البشريه لا اقارن كمان بنت وتر وانستقرام
فهو نشر تغريده قال فيها انه تويتر بيسبب
للناس الغضب وانستغرام بيسبب للناس
الاكتئاب وسائل الناس برايكم ايهما احسن
موضوع الانستغرام
يعني انا صراحه مثلا من الناس اللي كل هذه
الاشياء الانستغرام وتويتر وغضبي بس لا بس
برده اكثر متابعه طبعا عموما في احد
الردود في شخص قال لي ماسك انه تويتر ما
بيعصبه ابدا بالعكس هو طول النهار بيضحك
على تويتر ونصحوه انه للتخلص من الغضب انه
يلغي متابعه مراسلين والسياسيين
والاعلاميين ورد عليهم ماسك وقال له صحيح
انا بضحك كمان كثير على تويتر